vladimir putin es el único político no
italiano capaz de explicar en una
entrevista las ventajas de tener sexo en
grupo
algunos piensan que el sexo en grupo es
mejor que el normal porque hacen un
trabajo colectivo es más fácil
escaquearse pero ya te digo que es
cuestión de cada uno
supongo que esto es lo que aprendes
cuando haces estas visitas oficiales a
comida y silvio berlusconi pero hablando
de rusia y de penetraciones tenemos dos
noticias que en su día pasaron
desapercibidas por los medios pero que
son muy importantes la primera es que el
año pasado gazprom anunció que
duplicaría las perforaciones de petróleo
en el artículo
gazprom duplicó su producción de
petróleo en privado anaya el año pasado
la plataforma en el mar de pechora
produjo más de ochocientas mil toneladas
de petróleo en 2015 y la segunda es que
la semana pasada rusia anunció nuevas
operaciones militares en el ártico
project sin giros sin vender dirigiendo
infraestructuras clave para el ejército
ruso del ataque de los comandos
especiales de la otan y muchos pensaréis
que el polo norte no es más que la casa
de papá noel pero es mucho más
importante que todo eso para empezar es
uno de los mayores yacimientos del
petróleo del mundo y está prácticamente
inexplorado pero por encima de todo eso
el ártico puede ser una de las mayores
rutas comerciales a nivel internacional
simplemente mira desde mapa imaginaria
somos un barco que sale de inglaterra y
tiene que ir hasta japón hasta ahora
esta es la ruta que tendríamos que
seguir
sin embargo si pudiéramos ir por el
ártico podríamos ahorrarnos hasta la
mitad del tiempo
hasta hace 50 años era casi impensable
surcar el arco pero ahora la tecnología
para construir barcos rompehielos es
cada vez más barata de hecho casi todos
están en finlandia y aquí podemos ver
algunos ejemplos de barcos
tiene un problema y es que nadie sabe a
qué estado pertenecen durante años como
a casi nadie le importaba lo que ocurría
por esta zona lo que hicieron fue
dividir el casquete polar en gajos de
tal forma que cada gajo correspondería a
uno de los países colindantes uno para
rusia a otro para eeuu canadá noruega
dinamarca y finlandia sin embargo en
cuanto descubrieron que el polo norte es
una mina de oro dijeron cuidado cuidado
que estas fronteras ya no nos interesan
y ahí es cuando empezó a esta batalla
legal por ver qué parte corresponde a
cada estado si nos vamos al derecho
internacional cada nación tiene derecho
a 200 kilómetros de costa que serían sus
aguas territoriales sin embargo en este
caso hay bastantes disputas porque por
ejemplo noruega tiene esta isla que veis
aquí así que la teoría a la que se
agarran sobre todo rusia y noruega es la
de la plataforma continental es decir el
territorio nacional llegaría hasta dónde
llega la plataforma continental de cada
país pero claro como en el ártico hace
mucho frío y el mar está congelado
durante la mitad del año es muy difícil
comprobar hasta dónde llega tu
plataforma continental se han llegado a
hacer auténticas locuras para afianzar
la soberanía sobre el territorio por
ejemplo el año pasado rusia
voy al fondo del mar con una banderita
rusa para así poder decir que esa parte
de plataforma continental era suya
el caso de noruega literalmente
subvencionan con 30 mil euros al año a
todos los habitantes de esta isla es la
isla de svalbard solamente para poder
decir que tienen población noruega en
esa zona y poder reclamar que es suyo
pero la cosa no se queda aquí porque
también hay un problema ecológico según
dice greenpeace explotar el petróleo del
ártico causaría un daño tremendo al
medio ambiente de hecho distintos grupos
ecologistas han estado presionando tanto
el gobierno canadiense y al gobierno
americano para que no autoricen a ser la
empresa es el para que pueda hacer
perforaciones en esa zona cuando
intentaron hacer lo mismo en rusia les
metieron en la cárcel algo que en un
principio nos podría sonar habitual dado
el modo de gobierno de nuestro querido
amigo putting sin embargo en este caso
hubo algo llamativo y es que a las dos
semanas de encarcelar a dos activistas
de greenpeace les soltaron la comisión
de investigación rusa quería acusarlos
de piratería delito castigado con penas
de hasta 15 años de cárcel pero el
presidente ruso no está por la labor
esto no sólo eso además vladimir putin
salió a la prensa diciendo putin aprecia
a las nobles motivaciones de greenpeace
aunque condena sus métodos cuando putin
dice que tus intereses son
express hace temblar y aquí es donde
empieza la teoría de la conspiración
porque muchos dicen que putin podría
estar subvencionando en secreto a grupos
ecologistas en noruega canadá y eeuu
para así ser él el único que pueda
explotar el petróleo del ártico
personalmente yo creo que es casi
imposible justificar este tipo de
alianzas en la sombra lo que sí está
claro es que por ahora los grupos
ecologistas le vienen muy bien a los
intereses de rusia y que el gobierno de
putin necesita desesperadamente buscar
nuevos yacimientos de petróleo porque su
economía se está estancando y depende
prácticamente en su totalidad del grupo
por eso el hecho de que rusia esté
haciendo operaciones militares y no
láctico y está gastando tantísimo dinero
en adaptar su ejército para las
condiciones extremas del polo norte
significa que tienen muchísimo interés
en mantener su soberanía sobre esa zona
y prepararse para cualquier potencial
conflicto con noruega o con eeuu
repito que estamos hablando de una ruta
comercial importantísima y uno de los
mayores yacimientos de petróleo del
mundo
por su parte la unión europea también
quiere su trozo del pastel y jan han
propuesto a rusia algún tipo de
cooperación para explotar los recursos
del ártico ya os he dicho que finlandia
es el principal fabricante de barco
rompehielos del mundo lo que significa
que muy probablemente rusia necesitaría
la tecnología europea para poder
explotar el petróleo del polo norte esto
no hace sino meterle más hierro a la
cuestión
y todo esto en una zona totalmente
virgen totalmente desconocida por el ser
humano y que poco a poco estamos
empezando a descubrir por eso es un tema
que a mí personalmente me fascina el
resto os lo dejo a vuestra propia
interpretación en las próximas semanas
voy a volver a hablaros sobre putin
porque hay muchísima tela que cortar
sobre este personaje
mientras tanto suscribiros al canal si
no lo habéis hecho ya y nos vemos la
próxima semana un abrazo y hasta pronto